This is actually a little bit tricky. Even
though we've talked a lot about what
vocabulary is, sometimes it's hard to
apply it to actual situations. Let's start
from the bottom and work up. -100000 is
part of a term, but the term that it's
part of is actually -100,000x. Remember
that the term is the whole thing that's
going to be added to other things or
subtracted from other things. So -100000
on its own is not a term, so let's cross
that out. We said earlier that -100,000x
is a variable term as a whole, but it's
not the -100000 that makes the term a
variable term. It's the x that does that,
so, -100,000 itself is not a variable.
Constant was the word that we used for
numbers that were terms on their own,
things like 3 million right here. This is
something that is a term by itself that
has no variables as part of it. -100,000
is not standing on its own, it's
multiplied by x, so this is not a constant
either. That leaves us with coefficient.
Remember that coefficients are the number
parts of variable terms. So they are
numbers that are multiplied by variables
to create variable terms. I know there are
a lot of subtle differences involved in
this, but over time this will become a
much more natural feeling. Great job
working on all this vocab.